what's going on guys this is rob and in
this video we're going to be explaining
what happened
to geraldine at the end of episode 3 of
juan division as well as addressing the
mystery of ralph
because this is actually a really really
interesting concept and i think
i know what's going on with ralph so if
you guys saw the video that we did last
week we basically pitched your idea for
what we thought was going on in one
division and based on what we've seen in
this episode we were right anybody who
was walking around with this theory was
basically right not my theory per se but
the theory in general right was correct
i'm not going to be so arrogant as to
hog all the credit for myself even
though i'd love to
but anybody who had that theory i was
basically correct in this in the sense
that wanda is controlling everything i
was incorrect about the fact that vision
was in on it
obviously vision is not but at the end
of the episode we saw that geraldine had
seemed to have kind of come to her
senses or the very least
addressed the fact that pietro died at
the hands of ultron and because she
seemingly wouldn't reveal where she was
from or her identity or anything like
that she was thrown out by wanda now we
didn't really get the gritty details of
that as most of you guys know uh it
basically took place off screen
but we know that she's working for sword
we knew that by virtue of some of the
little emblems and and her necklace and
things like that that we'd seen
previously and the end of the episode so
that begs the question when she was
thrown out
where is she at well this is where
things get a little interesting the
running theory
is that doctor strange is currently out
there and doctor strange is dealing with
all this stuff
my theory is not yet and the reason why
is that if sword is an
entity unto itself which is to say the
sentient weapon observation
and response division or department
whatever you want to call it if they're
an entity unto themselves and they're
investigating this
then it would almost seem like the
marvel cinematic universe cutting them
off at the knees to have doctor strange
show up
immediately we'd want to know what sword
was capable of right what can sword
actually do and so what i think is going
on here right now
is that geraldine along with a handful
of other people who are basically in
this location
are working as agents of sword not all
of them right we know that like the
doctor for example i think is a citizen
inside or one of the people inside this
small town that was taken over by wanda
we know that like dottie for example is
a person who lives in this town
different things like that but geraldine
is one of these instances where she was
a sword agent who was sent in to
infiltrate i think she came into the
helicopter that wanda found in episodes
one and two that was shrunken down but
regardless of how she got in there she
was there to basically
keep an eye on things right to monitor
things to see what was going on and to
basically operate as something akin to a
spy wanda found out the jig was up and
she was kicked out right that's
basically how all that how all that
worked and so the result of this
is that at the moment i think it's just
sword right i think that's all it is
it's just sort the agency monitoring and
trying to find a way in this
impenetrable barrier and then once it
gets to the point where they cannot do
it then that will lead to the
introduction of doctor strange if i'm
being honest
i imagine benedict cumberbatch is going
to ask for a lot of money to appear in
one division so maybe one of these
things like when we saw samuel jackson
appear in agents of shield he shows up
in one episode and it's only for like
five or ten minutes
if that because it's all they can really
afford but we also know that with wand
division it's being ran by disney plus
right it's not like it was with agents
of shield and netflix the shows and all
that kind of stuff where they're running
on a limited budget it's the mouse right
the mouse is paying for it all right the
mouse has got the bill and when the
mouse has the bill you can kind of get
carried away with what you get so
it's entirely possible we could see
benedict cumberbatch show up in the next
episode and then basically say i'm here
to try to help you guys only for us to
learn that wanda's powers
actually exceed his own and there's no
way for benedict cumberbatch for doctor
strange to overcome what wand has done
and i think this is a genius idea
because if that proves to be the case
then what it does is it goes towards the
narrative that juan is going to have to
fix it on her own right one has to do it
by herself
because it would really seem to take
away from the entire purpose of wanda
vision
if like at the end of the series dr
strange swoops in and saves the day
right
at that point it's one division plus
doctor strange it didn't work
that dog don't bark and so i think this
is really gonna come down to steven
strange being able to offer a little bit
of help maybe talk to wana
telepathically or something like that or
offer some suggestions to agatha on what
she should do but the meat and potatoes
of this is gonna come down to wanda
fixing it all by herself now that begs
the question
how did we get to this point how did we
get to this point where wanda has
clearly taken over this town and
basically conscripted all these
different citizens living in this town
into being part of this sitcom type
lifestyle that she
loves so much right that she kind of
idolized when she was growing up
watching tv well i think this comes down
to agatha harkness and i think agnes or
agatha whatever you want to call her is
the root of all this
right and i think it goes into the
nature of her husband ralph and that's
what we're going to talk about here
one of the big prevailing theories about
the character of ralph is that ralph is
like mephisto
or cathone or something like that one of
the other theories is that like ralph
was killed
and agatha is just kind of pretending
he's still alive because she's not
supposed to know he's dead and so she
just kind of continues on
that theory sort of falls flat on his
face because if it was true why would
she refer to her husband in the present
tense why wouldn't she show even the
slightest bit of mourning over the fact
that her husband's dead why wouldn't she
just simply be like i don't know where
ralph is ralph's gone somewhere and and
why would she pretend he's still there
unless like
wanda killed ralph in front of her and
then is just like do not do this anymore
right do not mess around but if that was
the case
why would agnes act like she's just
meeting wanda for the first time in
episodes one and two
right so there's a lot of holes that go
on in that particular theory i'm of the
opinion that ralph is actually mephisto
and here's the reason why don't worry
this will all wrap around into what's
going on with wanda but i think i think
here's the reason why ralph was mephisto
so one of the things that agnes says
in the first and second episodes is that
the only way her husband ralph would
remember the anniversary of their
marriage is if there was a beer named
after june 2nd right so their
anniversary is on june 2nd june 2nd
1692 which is something that somebody
pointed out on twitter is when the salem
witch trials happened and so agatha
harkness and marvel comics is a
legitimate witch right the
cauldron and the you know sacrifice
killing like birds and you know
all that all that crazy stuff you know
like the movie hocus pocus she's similar
to that except not as goofy
but she is in that way a person who
would likely be tracked down and killed
during the salem witch trials assuming
that marvel decided to try to invoke
some version of the marvel comics origin
of her character into the marvel
cinematic universe now this is where
things shift that if she was blamed as
being a witch or accused of being a
witch most likely her husband would have
been accused as well she probably lost
her family in the process and that
in that moment soldier sold to the devil
right made a deal with mephista we
talked about that in the previous video
that mephisto is one of those
one of those hell lords that shows up to
you in a time when you're at your most
desperate and so if they're getting
ready to put the fire to the thing
they're getting ready to burn her alive
right and she's sitting there she was
like i would do anything to survive this
or something like that then again
everything would stop mephisto would
appear say what would you be willing to
do in order for this to
to you know end in the way that you
wanted to she'd offer some kind of an
answer mephisto would basically give her
the power she needs to overcome that so
then she would actually become a witch
you know or something like that
and then end up more or less saving the
day loser kids or loser husband in the
process whatever the case is none of
that stuff really matters the important
thing behind this
is that if that were true then a deal
would have to have been struck
with mephisto now the problem with this
theory and the problem with this
philosophy
is how do we connect these dots right
how do we bring these two things
together the reality is we don't really
have enough information
to do that right we don't really have
any enough information to link the
possibility of ralph being mephisto
to agnes as the current witch now in the
current state of affairs but where i
think a lot of this starts and the
reason why i think a lot of this really
comes down to agnes herself is that if
we remove ralph from the equation we
simply ignore him and we just pretend
that he's just
some guy who doesn't really exist and
agnes is just playing the part then we
look at her directly
agatha harkness in marvel comics was the
friend and
tutor of wanda then in early marvel
comics wanda didn't really have any
control over her powers or if she did
they were nowhere near as grand as they
would be later on in marvel comics
instead she had her hex probability so
she could basically bend luck in her
favor that's really the limit of her
powers now once she started receiving
uh instruction at the hands of agatha
that's when her powers began to grow
and i think that's what happened here
right somewhere along the line she was
either instructed to go visit agatha by
way of like steven strange or somebody
else or maybe stumbled into agatha of
her own accord and volition looking up
people who
are like her i don't we don't really
know what she was doing but by whatever
manner and whatever means agatha took
her under her wing and under the
training of agatha
wanda's powers began to grow and there
may have very well been some kind of
conversation between the two where
agatha is like tell me a little more
about your life and you know wanda
starts talking about losing pietro she
starts talking about losing her parents
she starts talking about losing these
different things and that's when she
suffers a psychotic break not in the
sense that she just goes
bonkers right off the bat but the wheels
in her brain start turning and then she
starts finding herself asking questions
what if i could make things the way that
i wanted them to be maybe i guess they
make some offhanded remark it's like
well wouldn't it be nice if we could
just make the world the way we wanted it
to be and then suddenly that turns into
well what if i could though
and using the powers that she now has
she starts to craft this dream life in
this small town
and there's nothing agatha can do to
stop her because she's simply just not
powerful enough and so agatha is in
effect
responsible for all of this it would
make sense for a variety of reasons it
would make sense because we know from
the trailers that agatha reveals to
vision that he's dead we know that
agatha is agatha harkness she's a witch
we know that while she does have magical
powers and abilities it would explain
why she doesn't have the ability to
overcome the power of wanda because
she's just
not on that same level there's a lot of
different reasons why i think this
theory works but at the end of the day
kind of circling back around to
geraldine i think geraldine has just
been expelled from the inside of the
dome
right the inside of this this little
town that wand has taken over she's
gonna report all her findings to sword
swords gonna realize there's only so
much they can do they're gonna bring in
doctor strange and that's going to lead
to benedict cumberbatch character being
part of one division even if only
temporarily but i hope you guys enjoyed
this video make sure you guys check the
videos that you have on the screen right
now you'll find one that'll explain
elizabeth olsen's character
and you'll find another video here that
will actually get you caught up on the
discussion that we had
from last week so anyway guys we're
going to bring this to an end thanks for
watching and i will catch you all later
peace